this flight uh if it does take off today
will have just a tiny handful of the
dozens that you were expecting to be on
that flight it's not really a deterrent
message to the people traffickers is it
we always said that this was going to be
a long process remember when i first
announced the policy i said it would
take a long time to get going there will
be plenty of legal challenges there will
be bumps on the road but i think what
opponents of the policy have to to say
is well what is your alternative what is
your alternative to
people being shipped across the channel
in very frail unseaworthy dinghies
risking their lives and undermining the
rule of law what's your alternative we
think it's a sensible partnership we've
set up with rwanda yes it may take a
while
to to get working properly but doesn't
mean we're not going to keep going
hundreds more have arrived today clearly
from the people trafficking point of
view it's worth the risk isn't it if
only a tiny handful are going to be
going in the very near future
perhaps into the medium term i think
it's very important that we continue to
show the people traffickers that their
business case is going to lead as is
being undermined and that they're
cheating people they're not only risking
uh their lives uh sending them across
the scene uh in unseen weather vessels
as i say but they're also
running the risk of them
being sent to another country which they
hadn't bargained for and they're
fundamentally ripping them off and
that's the message we need to get across
to those people traffickers you
predicted yourself that there would be
all these legal challenges and true
enough here we're seeing them is it not
time to come out of the european
convention of human rights to be able to
set your own rules to stack the odds in
your favor then when these legal
challenges come about that's certainly
the case that uh the
legal
uh fraternity sorority whatever
their legal world is very good at
picking up uh ways of of trying to stop
uh the government from
upholding what we think is
is a sensible law and trying to
we're trying to make a distinction
between
legal pathways to the uk which we
support we want people to be able to
come here in fear of their lives but we
want them to do it legally and safely
and that's why we have all the safe and
legal routes that are open to to people
what we want to do is to show the people
traffickers that
they're they're breaking the law they're
risking people's lives and it won't work
anyway now uh
if will it be necessary to
change some laws to help us
as we go along it may very well be and
all these options are under constant
review